раз раз раз два три раз
раз
раз раз раз раз
Андрій кудись втік 3 секунди А ось він
неможливо за вами слідкувати просто
де ти да нє ну В нас як в дитячому
садочку це більше схоже в нас довільний
формат все
раз раз
кожна менш важливий Він стосується
повітряної тривоги ми знаємо що таке
може бути як ми як ми працюємо в такому
випадку якщо у нас є під час якщо
тривога стається під час програми ми
зупиняємо програму всі організовано
виходимо на інститут У нас є ви вас на
звороті в Бена бейтчиках є намальована
карта де є виходи Їх є декілька тобто
навіть якщо ви не тут ви зможете
спокійно собі вийти і далі на вулиці вже
окремо організатори скерують вас в
укриття в Україні є багато місця ми всі
там по містумося Але ми не зможемо там
провести програму відповідно ви вже
будете слухати своїх кураторів І
модераторів наприклад там я можу вам в
навушниках сказати якщо у нас ще є час
ми повертаємося на попередню панель
договорюємо за рахунок каву перерви А як
не вже дуже довго повітря на тривога
тоді ми переходимо до наступної
наступного пункту програми але це вже
будемо вирішувати по суті
так і
наче наче все щодо інших питань коли
закінчується каву перерви коли нас
закінчуються дискусії Я також буду
нагадувати Отож я думаю ми готові
розпочати в нас сьогодні знаєте в
освітян Новий рік починається на 1 січня
а 1 вересня знаєте добре хочеться свято
Миколая в нас в грудні Бо якби було
стільки свято на вересень це було би
дуже складно от Вітаю у нас всіх за
початком нового нашого року я дуже
неймовірно тішуся що в нас є можливість
тут поспілкуватися що в нас є окремо
чудова панель дошкілля що в нас є
нарешті профільна заступниця з дошкілля
так і ми можемо собі в дуже вузькому
тематичному колі обговорити всі наші
питання не буду затримуватися не
затримувати час тому Давайте ми будемо
розпочинати і ми розпочинаємо з відео
будь ласка вас є екрани тут і тут будь
ласка увага на екран
це буде таке знаєте відео відкриття
урочисте відкриття саме нашої панелі
у найтемніші часи ми зберігаємо та
підживлюємо найважливіше світло в очах
дітей
іскристо цікавість
променистий захват від відкриттів
блискучо віру в те що можливо все
ми поряд щоб їхні перші кроки у світ не
загасили цей Вогонь і додавали
впевненості у власних
вчимо більшого ніж просто читати писати
і рахувати закладаємо критичне мислення
допомагаємо розуміти емоції розвиваємо
креативність
навчаємо спілкуватися і співпрацювати з
іншими
створюємо безпечний простір для проби
помилок що ж кожна ж і кожен набували
тих знань і навичок які допоможуть
гармонійно розвиватися взагалі
разом із батьками Ми радіємо успіхам
дітей і допомагаємо підтримати їх у
складних ситуаціях
ми світимося коли Вони діляться своїм
сяйвом ми з нами і точно знаємо Який
вигляд має світле майбутнє бо що
жнявчимо кожен його промінчик перемагати
будь-яку темряву
[музика]
Колеги давайте поаплодуємо один одному
за те що ми робимо таку важливу справу
виховуємо наших дітей змалечку І зараз я
хочу слово передати
Євгеній смірнові профільні заступниці
міністра освіти з дошкільної освіти та
інклюзії
колеги я вас всіх Вітаю чи мене чутно
зараз
майже нічого не чутно Так ти так А ось
так краще
так так краще Так Ну все тоді буду
використовувати цей мікрофон Я ви знаєте
насправді ви навіть собі не уявляєте
всередині які я зараз
емоції мене вони переповнюють Коли я
бачу кожного вас вживу ми можемо
обійнятись я обіймаю посаду на протязі 6
тижнів і насправді з більшості із вас ми
провели разом ці шість тиждень якраз в
обговореннях вузгодженнях в загальному
баченні а котра зараз мені хочеться
знати підрезимувати щоб ми його також
обговорили десь підкреслили може
важливість А може знайшли якісь нові
можливості для руху
ви знаєте найприємніші завжди
спілкувалися в колі однодумців і всі ми
з вами розумі ємо що це взагалі якісна
доступна дошкільна освіта це не тільки
про потенціал дитини це про суспільство
та державу в цілому
Не дивлячись А знаєте що і вже пан
міністр сказав що це була Воля
президента щоб з'явився заступник
Міністра саме з дошкілля ми з вами
працюємо в найпрості часи А за цей час
повномасштабного вторгнення Російської
Федерації в Україну було знищено
440 дошкільних закладів освіти і саме
страшне те що неможливо повернути про що
неможливо забути неможливо пробачити це
500-3 дитини це 1115 дітей але ці дані з
без урахування території котрі зараз
окуповані ворогом і на превеликий жаль
вони збільшиться коли туди буде доступ
Які в нас виклики звичайно покриття
це
61% дітей Хто мав доступ для дошкільної
освіти потім мені дуже хочеться щоб ми з
вами сконцентрувалися на надважливому і
я думаю тут не буде жодного і людини хто
буде в цьому суперечити це низька оплата
праці
із-за цього відтік по кадрів низький
Престиж професії і сукупні всі проблеми
ви знаєте мені хочеться займатися
найважливішим і коли в нас вихователі за
повний робочий день отримують 7 тисяч
500 гривень в кращому випадку це біда Ми
звичайно не можемо казати не можемо
мотивувати молодь А ще ми маємо казати
що люди хто приходять в садочки вони
несуть кримінальну відповідальність за
життя і здоров'я дітей і воно абсолютно
нерелевантне навіть порівняно з усіма
іншими ланками освіти і ми з вами тут
саме щоб це змінити ми маємо вибудувати
і знайти нові моделі А ми вже розпочали
цей процес Ми почали процес моделювання
да звичайно всі з нас розуміють є такий
знаєте одразу коли ми це обговорюємо
державна субвенція але що я хочу сказати
окрім державної субвенції є ще різні
механізми які можуть нам допомогти
підняти оплату праці
тут якраз друга фотографія вона була
згенерована штучним інтелектом що буде
якщо ми з вами цю битву програємо
а Вибачте це покриття я склав
61-66,1% мали доступ і 30% на
підконтрольній Україні території
призупинили свою діяльність в більшості
випадків це і за відсутності укриттів і
на жаль на даний час ще не тільки
донорами грантодавцями місцевими
громадами
отг надана допомога щодо якраз
побудови в деяких місцях або
облаштування укриттів в яких кадрів
звичайно коли садочки закриваються коли
починається простій
наші кадри котрі просто на ціну золота
пояснити ви знаєте пояснити в уряді що
мотивує людей за таку низьку заробітну
плату приходити і мати ще криміна
відповідальність от ми що це просто
шалене здоров'я кохання саме до дітей Ми
маємо це зупиняти А що мені хочеться
сказати і наголосити
вперше в історії в рамках Global teacher
Price будуть відзначені вихователі
Я вас прошу наведіть зараз на цей qr-код
подати від себе цих неймовірних жінок
іноді зустрічався і чоловіків наші
професії але це більш рідкість а подати
ці історії тому що саме ви знаєте ці
історії саме ви знаєте ті героїчні
вчинки котрі роблять виховательки
кожного дня коли вони вигадують нові
підходи коли вони зацікавлюють коли вони
працюють з батьками
А ще ми хочемо змінити і А як сказав вже
Михайло Федорів це не просто такі як
знаєте башня під кожним з цих пунктів
стоять проекти вже стоять люди котрі
готові чути котрі готові розуміти Якщо у
вас є конструктивні пропозиції Я вас
дуже прошу долучайтеся нам ми розуміємо
проблеми в професії нам треба спростити
і зробити легкий вхід в професію тому що
в нас недостатньо є кадрів велике відтік
ми маємо надати гарантоване місце кожній
дитині в дошкільної дошкільної освіти
в новому законопроекті котре проходить
ми ж першим і другим читанням є
фантастичні закладені зміни по різним
формам і наша з вами Саме тут задача це
і закон щоб він став реальністю щоб в
нас з'явилися мобільні дитячі садочки
щоб в нас з'явилися сімейні садочки і
підтримати наші комунальні садочки так
ой
а перехід від догляду до розвитку дитини
Я знаю що більшість вихователів це вже
займаються в нас є дуже класні потужні
напрацювання ми маємо їх підсилити Ну і
як я і казала і буду продовжувати казати
на вас система оплати праці
діти зокрема зоопарк здобувають
дошкільну освіту відповідно до
європейських вимог якості освіти та
змісту є європейська рамка якості всі
галузі вони оновлюють свої документи
вони оновлюють свої стратегії бачення з
урахуванням європейської рамки якості
українська дошкілля немає бути
виключенням
ми маємо оновити структуру та систему
науково-методичного забезпечення щоб в
дошкільних дитячих закладах була якісна
психологічна підтримка і звичайно раннє
виявлення особливих освітніх потреб та
якісна підтримка потім
дошкільної освіти кожен простір де
навчається наші дошкільнята мають бути
безпечним та інклюзивним безбар'єрним
повинні бути умови для функціонування
гнучкої та оптимальної мережі різних
типів надавачів послуг що мені тут
хочеться сказати
Україна
дала фантастично потужну відповідь
агресору
дошкілля немає стати виключенням ми
маємо підходити до надання наших послуг
де ми наприклад в нас є зруйновані
дитячі садочки і ми розуміємо що буде
потребувати певний час для їх
відновлення ми маємо запроваджувати
мобільний наприклад дитячий садочок
і система збору релевантних даних коле А
я вам дуже дякую що через систему Icon
вже знаєте як дошкільнята вони є
найкращим ви настільки швидко оперативно
заповнили форми Я думаю на кінець
наступного місяця ми вже систематизуємо
і приведемо і покажемо Вам всі дані
також нас чекає знаєте з 1 вересня
держборд котрий нам буде допомагати дуже
оперативно давати відповідь
на всі виклики котрі постають так да тут
да тут час колеги що мені хочеться
сказати на панелі з міністром Також тут
ми вам будемо ми надішлемо 8 ми її
можемо продовжувати обговорювати але я
дуже прошу давати не зупинятися бо
втіленні давати моделювати і розуміти як
ми можемо збільшити оплату праці наших
вихователів давайте розбудовувати нові
форми давайте давати доступ кожній
дитині до якісної дошкільної освіти
я як розумію Соломія зараз в мене просто
забирає пульт ну і саме головне давати
робити це разом тому що тільки наша
згуртованість може нам допомогти досягти
тих цілей котрі перед нами постають
[оплески]
Так Дуже дякую за такий натхненний
початок
у нас є величезне поле для роботи по
тому числі Тому зараз ми перейдемо до
нашої дискусії Я дуже попрошу вас на
екран ще одного спікера Дякую Отож
Дорогі колеги хочу представити наших
дорогих спікерів сьогодні з якими будемо
розмовляти це є Євгенія Смірнова
заступниця Міністр освіти і науки
України Це є норін язичан phd старша
Наукова співробітниця інституту розвитку
дитини імені Франка Портера Грема вона
нас підключається в Зумі Оксана Рома
керівниця освітніх ініціатив Lego
frientation в Україні і Христина шапок
керівниця центру гідності дитини
українська католицького університету
дякую
Давайте ми розпочнемо знаєте Наша перша
панель має бути такою дуже ціннісною або
ми з неї вийшли з крилами що от дошкілля
це якраз є перша і найважливіше з чого
починає дитина і ми всі розуміємо що
дошкілля це є така довгострокова
інвестиція в якому вкладаємо і насправді
якщо задуматися то саме з дошкілля
починається формування спільних
цінностей і формування громадянського
суспільства Бо насправді ті речі як там
взаємодія в соціумі повага повага до
себе повага до інших емпатія Вони
починаються з дитячого садка зі
звичайних Вибач Дякую будь ласка І
власне так і починається оцей фундамент
формування спільних цінностей і
відповідно я би хотіла би ми розпочали з
питань з питання до Євгенії
на вашу думку
як саме І що ми маємо транслювати в
дитячому садку які цінності і які
орієнтири ми всі разом маємо представити
нашим дітям вже починається починаючи з
дитячого садку для того аби знаєте
почати оці кроки до формування
відповідального громадянського
суспільства
Ви знаєте це мабуть найважливіше про те
що ми повинні говорити і говорити на
цьому рівні коли ми збираємось і це
Серпнева конференція і тут мені хочеться
підкреслити важливість наступного
наступного року наступного вересня сама
важлива це безпека
безпека в усіх розуміннях тут знаєте
оскільки в мене зараз є таке
така можливість сказати Будь ласка не
нехтуйте повітряними тривогами Я знаю що
в нашій Ланці це надскладно тому що якщо
в
початковій школі діти спускаються самі
ви несете дітей а не нехтуйте цим
починати слухати військові адміністрації
котрі роблять постійний моніторинг і
кажуть
Коли ми можемо працювати з вами і коли
на жаль в нас немає такої можливості
працювати
І в
хто Знаєте хто головний на сцені Мені
здається це саме головне це трикутник
дитина батьки і вихователь і Саме цей
трикутник має бути пронизане все наше
дошкілля і їх відносини між собою всі і
звичайно на благополуччя дитини на її
гармонійний розвиток але тільки такому
міцному трикутнику можливо буде
збудувати фундамент
Дякую дуже
так власне з цього трикутника і
починається фундамент оцих цінностей які
ми транслюємо нашим дітям
знаєте Ми добре Ми добре знаємо бо ми
тут сидимо що от дошкільний надзвичайно
важливим І власне що це є перша освітні
інституція з якою знайомляться батьки і
опікуни але я би хотіла або ми
повернулися до мови цифр і
аргументувати це власне певною
статистикою і дослідженнями і в мене
власне є питання до норі
які є дослідження та статистичні ідеї
які демонструють поза того результати
дошкільної освіти
і власне який є взаємозв'язок між
ранньою освітою і довгостроковим успіхом
тому що часто знаєте діти маленькі і
вважають що тоді Та маленькі то є освіта
маленька насправді це не так і мені
цікаво власне або ми підкріпили все те
про що ми тут говоримо справжнього
дослідженнями
А мене сім'я
[оплески]
[музика]
раз раз
Дуже дякую наразі за те що ви нам
додаємо такою наукової бази до наших
розмов ми насправді бачимо знаєте той
вплив на дитину бачимо це інвестицію з
роками коли дитина зростає там
відстоювати шести років от але дуже
важливо або це знаєте розуміла все
суспільство і ми всі були в одному
поняттям Полі що дошкілля це є перший
освітній інституція і вона є надзвичайно
важливою
Я би хотіла наступне питання також
знаєте ми так говоримо загалом про
освіту але
якісно доступно доступна освіта це ще
більше виклик в часі війни
і насправді я досить багато досліджень
про те що саме гра є
такою основою і надзвичайно важливою для
дитини яка перебуває в кризовій ситуації
яка перебуває в нашому випадку в стані
воєнного часу і я б хотіла запитатися У
Оксани
з вашого досвіду
Подивіться будь ласка з нами яке саме
якийсь вплив має гра на
дитину під час крижаної ситуації і
насправді може надати нам рекомендації
що нам всім подарувати потрібно
врахувати при організації гри дитини
України 2010 року ми розпочинали саме з
дошкілля і перед тим як перейду до
відповіді на запитання Хочу зазначити що
коли ми говоримо про гру і ми говоримо
про гру взагалі як універсальний
механізм як світогляд як спосіб мислення
педагога і от нещодавно у нас була
затверджена парціальна програма творці
майбутнього програма розвитку дитини
через гру яка пропагує гру як наскрізний
спосіб взаємодії не тільки педагога а й
дорослого із дитиною особливо
актуальними питання гри стають зараз
насправді поняття гри є не до кінця
дослідженим і на сьогодні світова
Наукова спільнота знову повертається для
того щоб зрозуміти А в чому ж насправді
такий глибинний феномен гри в
університеті Кембридж Навіть є заснована
кафедра гри і є професор гри але коли ми
говоримо про гру ми говоримо не про
рутини 5-хвилинний момент ми з вами
говоримо про спосіб світобуття для
дитини про спосіб мислення педагога і в
Україні Ми не тільки послуговуємося за
кордонними дослідженнями а й в Україні в
нас зараз також змінюється Гради дитини
дитина потребує набагато більше участі
дорослого у грі на сьогодні щоб дорослий
був поруч гра дитини зрозуміло який
сюжети програються сьогодні це військові
сюжети воєнні сюжети діти грають у
волонтерів і так далі але є одна така
дуже важлива річ що наші діти не
програють агресорів не програють сюжети
щоб убити когось вони програють все для
того щоб захистити свою домівку
захистити свою маму тата сестричку і так
далі і тому нам як освітянам нам як
вихователям потрібно повернутися до того
механізму який дійсно природовідповідним
дитині ту який найшвидше допоможе дитині
впоруватися із стресовими ситуаціями і
всіма кризами подіями де перебуває
дитина гра може слугувати не тільки
способом може замінити навіть мовленнєве
спілкування дітей особливо тоді коли є
мовний бар'єр в нас багато дітей за
кордоном знаходиться тоді коли дитина не
може або не хоче розповісти про ті події
які вона пережила гра також є дуже
важливою для підтримки когнітивного
розвитку дітей Ми говоримо про те що
зараз нам потрібно дбати про безпеку
дітей але в той же час коли ми залучаємо
даємо можливість дитині програвати різні
історії особливо це сюжетно-рольові ігри
Ми підтримуємо розвиток когнітивної
сфери дитини що не буде уповільнювати її
процес пізнання якщо ми говоримо про гру
це також спосіб зменшити рівень стресу і
під час гри дитина розвиває самоконтроль
а самоконтроль є надзвичайно важливим у
подоланні дитиною саме стресу якщо ми
говоримо про нас як вихователів Що нам
робити передусім стати втричі
активнішими спостерігачами слухачами
того що відбувається з дитиною почути
побачити бо іноді є там де ми можемо
бути помічними А є ситуації коли нам
треба вчасно не прогледіти зреагувати І
направити далі до психолога чи до інших
фахівців це один момент а другий момент
зважаючи на всі з якими ми маємо справу
десь матеріали не в повному об'ємі і так
далі але те що ми маємо на сьогодні
створювати умови і простір для дитини
для гри в ситуації тут і зараз з тим що
є і де ми є адже будь-який простір для
гри надає відчуття дитині стабільності і
безпеки що повертає до певного такого
сенсу нормальності Коли все навколо може
здаватися абсолютно ненормальним не
певним і невизначеним Тому це передусім
чітке усвідомлення педагогам безцінного
ресурсу гри Який давно у нас
задекларований але зараз на нього треба
подивитися по-іншому
Дякую Оксана абсолютно погоджуюся бо
власне знаєте під час гри дитина
повертає контроль собі вона
стабілізується і вона розуміє що вона
впливає на щось в цьому житті бо На жаль
ми всі зараз не можемо так знаєте твердо
сказати я впливаю на щось бо наше життя
може в будь-який момент перервати
повітря на тривога і саме в грі дитина
контролює створює і бачить результати
свого своєї гри
знову ж таки до питання безпеки ми вже
сьогодні говорили про укриття і ми
розуміємо що це є невід'ємною такою от
основою того що має бути в кожному
закладі освіти сьогодні але окрім
укриття також є і інші моменти безпеки
про які треба проговорити і
я би хотіла або ми замислилися Які ще
такі можливо не очевидні елементи по
безпанції ми можемо впровадити кожен в
своєму дитячому садку на що саме
потрібно звернути увагу тому що безпека
- це не лише про фізичну безпеку Це в
тому числі і психоемоційна безпе ка І
власне я би хотіли поставити питання
Христині
що вже сьогодні може зробити кожен
заклад освіти для того аби швидко
зреагувати під час кризової ситуації
перевіримо чи мене чути
та дякую за запитання власне Я хочу
почати
з такого що Знаєте Ми чуємо себе в
безпеці коли наш стрес є контрольований
і передбачуваний і ви знаєте що малі
діти дуже часто просять вас читати одні
і ті самі казки або розказувати одні й
ті самі історії Чи ті самі книжки Отже
Таким чином вони можуть контролювати
ситуацію бо вони знають що буде в кінці
які не буде точно Добре або такий яких
для неї є прийнятний Отже для того щоб
діти чулися в безпеці середовища в якому
вони є має бути передбачуваним і
контрольованим
тому навіть коли лунає повітряна сирена
і ми спускаємось в укриття Вони знають
Ці правила Вони знають що будуть в кінці
це гра і тут дуже важливо для відчуття
безпеки реакція дорослого Ми в нас в
університеті зробили таке дослідження
власне дослідили як реакція батьків
впливає на
психічний
психологічний стан дітей і результат був
такий що впливає прямо там від того
наскільки
тривожиться батьки від того наскільки
яскравою їхня реакція
залежить поведінка спокій сприйняття
того що відбувається дітей тому власне
реакція дорослих поведінка дорослих які
важливими для дітей вихователь наставник
Вчитель це є завжди важлива людина для
дитини
Своєю поведінкою своїм сприйняттям
реальності впливає на те чи дитина
почувається в безпеці я навмисно кажу
почувається в безпеці тому що бути в
безпеці і почуватися в безпеці це є
різні речі ми можемо бути в безпеці
вдома але ми можемо не почуватися тому
що ми можемо тривожитися через те що
батьки говорять на кухні чи через те що
Батьки сваряться чи ну чи через якісь
інші речі через те що вихователь мене не
вкусить в туалет якщо я захочу під час
тихої години там а ми можемо не бути в
безпеці а бути в укричі коли летять
ракети Коли ми чуємо вибухи але
почуватися в безпеці тому що біля нас є
надійний дорослий якийсь спокійно реагує
і його впевненість передається нам чому
вона нам передається малим дітям тому що
в нас немає достатнього досвіду в нас не
сформована лобна кора в нас немає
достатньо критичного мислення ми
зчитуємо поведінку з дорослих і
відтворюємо її дзеркалимо І власне отак
все цікаво відбувається що ще хочу
цікаве сказати це про такі знаєте
психологічні фактори але є речі які ми
можемо зарегулювати і зарегулювати ми
можемо це політиками безпеки тобто
певними правилами які передбачають
закони але які стосуються нашої
поведінки нашого стосунку відносно
дитини тому що якщо ви спробуєте згадати
свого найкращого вихователя Ви точно не
згадаєте що він вас навчив Ви точно не
згадаєте Чи це саме цей вихователь вас
навчив цифру 5 чи інший вихователь вас
навчив цифру 5 але ви точно його
згадаєте тому що він до вас добре
ставився ви відчували що він вас любить
І що ви йому
потрібні в дитячому віці так тому власне
деякі речі можна зарегулювати так
званими політиками безпеки тобто
правилами поведінки з дитиною як ми
поводимось як ми говоримо як Ми не
говоримо як ми кричимо як мене кричимо
ми не кричимо Скільки дорослих має бути
на дитину як ми реагуємо як ми
звертаємось очі Ми звертаємось діти чи
ми звертаємось друзі чи ми звертаємось
на ім'я і так далі там І власне коли
правила будуть єдині для всієї освітньої
установи знаєте тоді в нас буде добре
середня температура по палаті не буде
знаєте що хтось краще вихователь хтось
гірше Я хочу свою дитину в ту групу Я
хочу в ту буду єдиний стандарт де діти
всі будуть почуватися в безпеці і для
батьки будуть відчувати що що їхні діти
є в безпеці
хочу сказати що найкраще вихователь який
творить безпеку для дитини це той який
має добрий стосунок і я думаю що ми про
це постійно маємо пам'ятати що Незалежно
від того чи діти в цей момент є в
безпеці чи не є безпеці Вони мають
почуватися в безпеці це перше що я хочу
зафіксувати і друге що я хочу також
зафіксувати це те що
коли ми дорослі робимо страх дитини
контрольованим і передбачуваним то
діти почуваються дуже спокійно навіть в
ситуаціїх які для нас дорослих видаються
не зовсім безпечними
Дякую дуже
тому який висновок нам в першу чергу
треба дбати про себе і завжди треба про
це пам'ятати тому що коли ми в ресурсі
Ми пам'ятаємо про це а насправді коли в
нас що в нас ресурсу цього немає Немає
кому про нас подбати в нас немає свого
вихователя який скаже де попи і води
Відпочинь положи тому ми дорослі
відповідальні за дітей маємо пам'ятати
що все починається з нас особистого
прикладу як ми будемо дбати про себе
відстоювати свої межі так само ми і
будемо цього вчити дітей і треба дуже
знаєте про це пам'ятати собі
я би ще хотіла підняти питання власне ми
тут всі зібралися з різних громад і ми
всі їсти колдерами освіти і насправді
для того аби ми якісно реалізували ту
стратегію які операційні цілі і про які
розповідали Євгенія нам всім потрібно
обов'язково об'єднатися об'єднатися
батькам освітянам місцевому управлінні і
питання до Євгенії
як якими конкретними кроками ми можемо
співпрацювати
аби забезпечити стале партнерство з
місцевими громадами тобто що нам усім
необхідно зробити От вже зараз для того
аби якісна і доступна освіта була
пріоритетом завжди навіть в дуже
складних обставинах
дуже цікаве питання неочікуване
А мені здається навчитися перше це
давати
екологічний
зворотній зв'язок Тому що іноді ми не
завжди це вміємо робити нас на жаль не
завжди вчили в наших школах наших
садочках і давати зворотний зв'язок так
Щоб нас почули так щоб до нас побачили і
так щоб наші проблеми їх переорітивали
зі свого боку Я хочу сказати що на базі
Міністерства освіти і науки
вже працюють декілька робочих груп вони
будуть розширені і ми будемо долучати
всіх бажаючих до
конкретних кроків впровадженню до
конкретних дій будь ласка коли ми
анонсуємо обговорені візі нам дуже
сильно хочеться побачити в цього року в
нас було 60 учасників обговорення
початковій школі 410
нам хочеться щоб минулого наступного
року в нас було 500 Ну а школи вже як
складеться
Я вас дуже прошу будьте проактивними
пишіть нам звертайтеся не тільки нам
звертайтеся до громад ініціюйте процеси
хто з керівників закладів дошкільної
освіти також звертайтеся пишіть пишіть
на всіх На всіх рівень на всіх рівнях А
коли ви мовчите воно нічого не рухається
і нічого неможливо зробити для вас без
вас а ви знаєте в усьому світі а
неможливо моделювання будь-якої
соціальної послуги медичної послуги
в дитячому садку без стейкхолдерів ви є
тими стейкхолдерами давайте постійно
зворотний зв'язок долучайтеся і говоріть
Дякую дуже
окремо коли ми говоримо простий холдерів
важливо
підняти питання окремої категорії
стійколдрів це є внутрішньо переміщених
сімей Бо насправді знову ж таки ми
говоримо про все в контексті війни
і тут важливо згадати про внутрішньо
переміщених дітей і сім'ї
Я би хотіла на наступне питання знову ж
таки повернути до Христини бо хрести вже
почали розповідати про те як от ми
вихователі може придбати про дитину як
нам адаптувати
переміщених дітей і разом з тим знаєте
зробити добре добре такий майданчик і
платформу для переміщених сімей Тому що
їм Також потрібно підтримка і як ми
спільно батьки дитини і садок можемо
адаптувати цю дитину в новому середовищі
і як садок може стати підтримуючим
середовищем для цих сімей бо я розумію
на садок насправді лягає величезна
відповідальність і дуже багато
обов'язків Але можливо ми все ж таки
можемо знаєте
Не складним ресурсом
допомогти їм адаптуватися швидше
та дякую за це запитання знаєте мені
завжди коли кажуть внутрішньо переміщена
особа трохи сипається одне з очей по
черзі тому що мені дуже не подобається
це слово тому що
воно робить нас
різними А на кожного з особливістю
знаєте і я думаю що
це таке навіть трохи
недоречна виріз знання Я думаю що кожна
людина яка є в нас в групі в садочку
кожна сім'я має може потребувати
допомоги Яка сім'я тому що вона пережила
обстріли втратила дім змінили місце
проживання якась сім'я тому що вона
агресує до своєї дитини і б'є її вдома і
ми це бачимо якась сім'я тому що там є
залежності якась сім'я тому що там є
якесь скривчення сексуального
зловживання Я не знаю насильства і так
далі І ми чомусь на інші ці проблеми
звикли закривати очі і ми знаємо Чому Бо
це в нас в культурі наших Та скраю або
ми не виносимо сміття з хати та і не
реагувати в соцслужбу вважати що цей
справа цієї сім'ї а ніби окрема
категорію яка зараз є в нас дуже на
слуху Ми звикли Ми хочемо наче їм дуже
допомогти я думаю перше що треба
запитатися чи вам потрібно наша допомога
це перше що треба зробити і якщо якщо
така допомога потрібна то яка допомога
вам потрібна так то я думаю що ми не
можемо знаєте свої послуги з інтеграції
якось так дуже
шаблонно пропонувати Але я думаю що всі
люди мають базові потреби і базова
потреба є в прийнятті і любові я думаю
що якщо ми в наші середовища людей які
приїхали Приймемо такими як вони є дамо
їм відчуття безпеки хоча б тут бо тому
що є ще питання найму житла пошуку
роботи і так далі Та що тут ми подбаємо
про ваших дітей Поки ви влаштовуєте своє
життя це вже буде супер добрим ми маємо
пам'ятати що в цих сімей може бути
високий рівень тривожності щоб цих сімей
може бути Знаєте таке якесь заповільнена
реакція але ми точно не можемо
збільшувати їхній рівень агресії та І
власне
Я думаю що ключове тут це
ставитися так як до всіх Я думаю що
найбільше за все вони хочуть повернутися
до нормального життя і ми якби маємо
дати їм ту можливість А якщо вони будуть
потребувати якоїсь особливої уваги
допомоги тоді ми можемо їм запропонувати
або порадити
спеціалістів чи гарячій лінії чи
консультації дає можуть глибше допомогти
вирішити проблему
Дякую Христю
Я хочу знаєте зробити такий
по-перше в нас залишилося 8 хвилин а в
мене ще є два питання Я маю обов'язково
їх поставити але я хочу зробити такий
знаєте підсумок короткий що ми вже
поговорили про те що
дошкільна освіта впливає на економічну
ситуацію тому що освічена освічена
суспільство
сприяє економічному зростанню і це є
факт І ще дуже важливо ми ми вже
поговорили про те що ми впливаємо на
формування громадського громадянського
суспільства і ще важливо також згадати
про те що
коли в нас діти
мають майданчик мають можливості для
розвитку креативності для розвитку своєї
допитливості ми Таким чином створюємо
поступ до інновацій і до наукових
технологій бо це також знаєте про
цікавість дуже життя про інтерес і
власне питання також до Оксани як ми
можемо в наш оцей складний час
посилити креативність в освітніх
системах зараз і в майбутньому тому що
знову ж таки у тому всьому знаєте
круговороті повітряних тривог
операційних задач також щоденного
рутинного життя дуже Важливо пам'ятати
от знаєте про оці такі пропорції там
градити не креативність дитини що ми
можемо зробити вже зараз і в майбутньому
на що потрібно звернути увагу
Дякую Соломії за запитання власне коли
ми говоримо про креативність от ви
згадали що зараз такий час ми його або
розцінюємо час провалу або час квантових
стрибків і квантових можливостей
нещодавно познайомилися з працею
аналітичного центру аналітичного
дослідницького інституту Штатах брукінг
які опублікували книгу про про три
тисячі інновацій освітніх інновацій в
різних куточках світу і потім звели ці
всі інновації до таких ключових
висновків один з ключових висновків є те
що 70% усіх цих інновацій використовують
ігровий і діяльністьний підхід про що це
говорить нам як педагог нам як
вихователь якщо ми вже маємо в руках ті
інструменти які ми можемо
використовувати для розвитку
креативності другий момент який ми
повинні пам'ятати це про те що дуже
довго побудувала думка що ми всі
народжуємося креативними геніями а
довіку 25 років два чи три відсотки з
нас такими залишаються так от я хочу це
спростувати немає жодного доказу у світ
який доводить що це дослідження
коли-небудь здійснювалося
натомість сьогодні світ переформульовує
визначення креативності і надає цьому
визначенню не тільки як якість яка у нас
є а цементальний м'яз який потрібно
постійно тренувати тобто креативність
можна тренувати Але чому от говорять
таку про таку зв'язку діти і дорослі
тому що в нас переважають різні типи
креативного мислення у дітей це
переважно дивергентне мислення коли ви
мене можуть експериментувати
досліджувати не боятися ризиків у
дорослих - це конвергентне коли вони
можуть побачити як ту чи іншу ідею
застосувати відповідно до контексту і
сьогодні багато країн світу зокрема в
Данії та країни яка мені дуже близька за
родом діяльності дуже часто говорять про
те що чути голос дитини чому потрібно
чути голос дитини Тому що іноді дитина
може підказати те рішення на які
дорослими можемо не наважитися а Наша
задача вже його зреалізувати у
відповідному контексті тому сьогодні
було питання про громади про те як ми
взаємодіємо потрібно більше чути дітей і
давати їм можливість для розвитку у грі
тому що гра вона сама приведе до
розвитку креативності
Дуже дякую тому ми йдемо звідси вже
завжди вам висновком можливо дбати про
себе і давайте дітям бавитися
Так на жаль на жаль треба ставити
останнє питання І в нас буде по хвилині
на кожного спікера на це питання Я
надіюсь що це питання буде натхне для
нас всіх Ви знаєте Ну тут говоримо про
такі великі високі матерії про там вплив
про внесок розвиток дітей про економічне
зростання але насправді за цим всім
стоїть вихователь
вихователь є обличчям дитячого садка є
обличчям цілою освітньою інституції
вихователь є тим чиїми руками доходять
пропозиції заступниці міністр правильно
І власне все заключається на людському
ресурсі і на тому як ми транслюємо світ
нашим дітям
і таке питання до кожного зі спікерів бо
вихователь це є важливий дорослий в
житті дитини так само як і батьки так
само як і опікуни як нам залишатися в
ресурсі і бути підтримкою дітям і що ми
можемо наприклад вже завтра на рівні
садка і на особистому рівні педагога
зробити Я б хотіла спочатку аби
відповіла норін і тоді ми перейдемо вже
по по бажанню до кожного зі спікерів але
одягніть будь ласка навушники
питання так Перепрошую ви знаєте тут
дуже багато Ти всіх технічних моментів
як залишатися ресурсом і бути підтримкою
дітям і що ми можемо впровадити на рівні
садка або на рівні педагога
або мені виключили
можеш говорити Да це було третє питання
Перекладіть будь ласка
[музика]
Дякую дуже так дорогі колежанки в нас
тут окремо дискусія почалася Знаєте
хто би хотів з вас відповісти першим на
питання як вихователю бути в ресурсі під
час війни і що ми вже можемо зробити от
завтра ми вертаємося всі додому Ми з
понеділка приходимо в садок що ми можемо
зробити зразу конкретні кроки
Та я так розумію Ми дуже обмежені в часі
тому я спробую за 30 секунд я з собою
взяла тримаю в руках це такий інструмент
який ми на сьогодні розповсюджуємо через
інститути післядипломної освіти в рамках
курсу психосоціальної підтримки дітей і
педагогів інструмент називається квітка
благополуччя який розроблений
міжнародним комітетом порятунку це
інструмент про сфери нашого благополуччя
емоційний соціальний матеріальне
когнітивне і духовне дуже легкий у
використанні Іноді дуже такі прості речі
філіжанка кави з колегою просто розмова
може допомогти нам багато про що я не
буду зараз заглиблюватись бо він Досить
Да такий ємний інструмент але в нас на
локації він представлений можна підійти
і його також отримати
Так я від себе так скажу що я думаю що
важливо не боятися робити для дитини а
не для знаєте для батьків чи для себе
тобто і думати чи те що ми робимо є в
найкращих інтересах дитини наприклад чий
дитині важливо доїсти ту котлетку Чи це
зробить її щасливішим якщо її заставлять
це зробити Чи це зробить щасливішими вас
І ви будете почувати себе добре
вихователькою І ці батьки ви будете мати
що розказати так а вона це запам'ятає як
просто що ну це було травматично для неї
в дитинстві Так отже
завжди діяти в інтересах дитини Тоді вам
буде легше та якщо дитина хоче бавитись
вона бавиться якщо вона не хоче їсти
вона не їсть це все окей Я не чула що
ніколи в житті Щоб в дитячому садку
дитина померла від голоду
і я думаю коли ми будемо менше ресурсу
витрачати на непотрібні речі то більше
залишатиметься для нас щоби бути в
ресурсі
Мені здається найважливіше що може бути
це дбати про своє ментальне здоров'я
тому що все починається
з вас як управлінців як вихователів
кожного дбати про свій фізичний стан не
забувати самим пообідати і самим як вже
сказали колеги випити каву
переключитися і намагатися помічати
позитивні дрібниці знаєте і їх
підкріплювати і щоб вони потім
проростали таке зерно і наповнювали і
насичували вас
Дякую дуже Ну як я і казала ми закінчили
натхненній ноті
дорогі спікери дорогі друзі Ми вже стали
друзями починали з колега закінчили
друзями
Я хочу вам всім дуже подякувати за те що
ви тут з нами і що ми мали йому
можливість поспілкуватися і навіть
технічні моменти нам не завадили ми все
ж таки все гарно організували зараз хочу
перш за все подякувати нашим спікерам
А зараз в нас є 10 хвилин щоб подбати
про себе попити кави взяти собі тістечко
і повернутися сюди на наступну сесію
практикум дуже цікаво тому будь ласка не
затримуйтесь ми вже будемо йти згідно по
розкладу дуже Всім дякую
о 13:30 ми починаємо
[музика]
для дитини це справжній друг учитель
наставник і людина до якої дитини біжить
в обійми і саме ці люди закладають нашим
дітям впевненість в собі впевненість в
тому що вони можуть Знайти вихід із
будь-яких ситуацій Дорогі наші любі
вихователі ви першими навчаєте наших
дітей що таке добро
що таке ви навчаєте їх дружити бути з
собою любити величезну роботу для того
щоб наша нація була не просто розумна ще
й здорова Саме від вашого першого
доторку залежить те якими будуть наші
дітки дай дитині
із дитиною виросте хороша людина здатна
творити щось прекрасне
зараз ставши багатодітною мамою і
повівши своїх малюків у дитсадочок я
розумію наскільки це титанічна і важлива
справа ми як батьки трьох дітей про це
не уявляємо що кожного дня переживаєте
Ви тому ми насправді вами захоплюємось
бажаю всі вихователям отримувати
навзаєм таку ж любов яку ви віддаєте
своїм вихованцям бажаю терпіння здоров'я
щоб попри такий важкий складний час ви
все одно мали цю жагу ростити виховувати
найкрутіших українських дітей Дякую вам
дякую що ви є Дякуємо любимо
[музика]
на першій ми з вами говорили про такі
знаєте високі
високі цінності про важливість
дошкільної системи про важливість нашого
щоденного внеску в розвиток
громадянського суспільства на другій ми
спустилися до себе і подбали про себе
навчилися як заземлятися як
повертати своє тіло в норму і бути
ресурсом для дітей і звичайно ж ми зараз
поговоримо про дітей тому що
без дітей дитячого садка Нікому не
потрібно ми це розуміємо і є дуже рада
що наша наступна Панельна дискусія буде
спокусована на дитині я урочисту передаю
мікрофон модераторці Анастасії
коноваловій яка є фахівчиною з
дошкільної освіти дитячого фонду ООН
юнісеф в Україні
колеги Добрий день дуже рада вітати і
по-перше дуже рада вітати справжніх
патріотів дошкільної освіти які
залишились на останню сесію дожили каву
попили бутерброд з'їли і повернулись це
значить це оціна на кому все тримається
вони тут зараз дуже рада вас вітати дуже
хоче щоб наша дискусія Наша розмова була
теплою і дуже вам пропоную залучатись до
нашого обговорення будь ласка піднімайте
руку я піднесу мікрофон Тому що дуже
важливо почути тут є практики тут є
керівники тут є вихователі дуже важливо
нам почути вас а не тільки щоб це було в
форматі лекції а також я дуже горда або
ти на одній сцені з цими чудовими людьми
на яких трималося останні роки дуже
багато чого що стосується дошкілля ну
почну з Юлії найди бо вона просила з нею
не починати і
і воно знаєте Не починати з Юлії найди
на початку Юлія Найда А вона виконавча
директор всеукраїнського фонду крок за
кроком і вона останні
десятиріччя бореться з інклюзивно світу
в дошкіллі і в школі в цілому а також є
викладачку кафедри соціального
інклюзивної освіти університету
Грінченка тому пані Юлія дуже рада і
Пробачте а далі в нас пані Марина столяр
вона програмна директорка Сезам воркшоп
а в Україні і президента міжнародної
асоціації гри дуже багато чули про гру і
тепер ще почуємо іще раз але вже з іншою
перспективи Ну звичайно наша
рок-зірка
пані Катерина крутій пані кратерина
крутій доктор педагогічних наук
професорка кафедри дошкільної освіти
Вінницького державного університету
імені Михайла Коцюбинського напевно Мало
хто з нас не підписа на соцмережі пані
Катерини і багато хто знаєте сидів
сьогодні їв бутерброди казав ви відчули
Що пані Катерина крутий буде сьогодні на
на виступати а пані Катерина теж це чула
тому дуже-дуже радять Ну звичайно моя
улюблена колега моя Partner in Crime
Анастасія Золотухіна Шкурко вона
фахівчиня з
соціально-поведінковим змін яка
дуже-дуже напевно краще за всіх знає
батьків дошкільнят то почуємо від неї А
що в нас з батьками що Вони думають цей
складний час ну і до вас блатнот долі -
це я персонально
фанатка пані Ніно омеляненко це людина
якій можна о 2-й ночі Подзвонити
запитати А в якій статті якого
підзаконного акту про це йдеться і вона
швиденько скаже і завжди допоможе і
направить куди треба А ще вона є головою
правління найбільшою асоціації
працівників дошкільної освіти куди в
ходять 5
5 тисяч вихователів тому ви бачите
панель в нас дуже експертна дуже
професійно хотіла б кожного з вас також
представити бо впевнена що про кожного І
кожну можна багато чого розказати а тому
будь ласка доєднуйтесь до дискусії і
коли дояднитись представляйте себе дуже
прошу можемо починати в нас така тема
дитина в ЕКО в екосистемі дошкільної
освіти в умовах війни і коли ми кажемо
про екосистему це ж про все це і про
батьків і про дітей і про вихователів і
про програму навчання і про освітній
простір Ну все-все-все що стосується
дошкілля створює екосистему і в мене
перше питання Ну звичайно до Юлі найди
бо вже так ми почали пані Юля скажіть
будь ласка в умовах війни Хто в нас
ключові гравці в цій екосистемі хто її
створює і чи достатньо я взаємодії між
цими
елементами дякую
Доброго дня
по-перше перед тим як почати про
екосистему дітей батьки і всіх інших Я
хочу вам щиро подякувати за ту величезну
роботу яку ви здійснюєте з 24 лютого
22-го року по сьогоднішній день на вас
тримається все дошкілля на вас
тримається батьки на вас тримаються діти
велика вам шана і подяка за ту роботу
яку ви робите І ця екосистема стійка
завдяки вам
сьогоднішньої екосистема дошкілля стій
за рахунок того що вихователі батьки
взаємодіють і спілкуються і працюють
разом хочеться сказати що сьогодні в цей
важкий час час війни насправді
екосистема трошки не є стікою не є
стікою тому що у нас є багато викликів
до яких ми не готові або але ми
навчаємось їх долати це виклики які
пов'язані з війною стресом відсутністю
вихователів відсутністю садочків
відсутністю у багатьох дітей батьків є
опікуни тобто система на сьогоднішній
день потребує величезної підтримки
величезної підтримки потребують педагоги
величезної підтримки потребують батьків
які і педагоги і батьки впливають на
дітей і за останній час багатьма
організаціями в Україні були проведені
дослідження
Дослідження які говорять що саме
вихователі Сьогодні мають величезний
стрес і величезне напруження працюючи з
дітьми працюють з педагогами і працюючи
з батьками і зі своїми колегами хочу вам
хочу може багато розказувати про
дослідження єдине що хочу сказати про
дослідження які сьогодні проводиться що
ці дослідження показують нам що наше
вихователі докладають багато зусиль
багато зусиль для того щоб дитина була в
центрі цієї екосистеми Разом з тим дуже
важливо допомогти вихователям
співпрацювати не лише з дітьми А спів
пропрацювати із батьками допомогти
вихователям відпрацювати щоденну
методику як вітатися
як запитувати про справи І чи варто про
них запитувати
подумати про те як допомогти вихователям
налагодити свій внутрішній баланс Як
сьогодні розповідала Світлана Рось як
допомогти дошкільному закладу в цілому
співпрацювати з новою громадою громадою
яка змінилась докорінна Ви самі працюєте
в громадах І знаєте ці громади
говорячи про екосистему не можу не
сказати про дуже добре відомий вам ekers
ekers як методику яка допомагає
вихователю знайти внутрішні ресурси
знайти можливості як співпрацювати з
дітьми саме На нашу думку і на думку
дослідників еkерс Може сьогодні
насправді розкритись найбільшим способом
над допомогу вихователю створюючи
середовище Спілкуючись з батьками і
Спілкуючись з дітьми також хочу сказати
що ця екосистема навколо дитини вона
формується не лише в стосунках між
вихователем і дитиною а формується в
стосунках між дітьми і дітьми
І от саме в цьому також полягає наш
виклик сьогодні як допомогти маленьким
дітям налагодити взаємодію між один з
одним і сьогодні ви будете буде
спілкуватися з пані Катериною яка
представить дуже важливі речі буде
говорити і Марина і і Пані Катерина і
всі інші будуть говорити про гру
хочу сказати що сьогодні ми маємо чудову
можливість
за страшних умов Змінити наше дошкілля
дати дітям більше вільної самостійної
гри
гри яка допомагає дітям і розвиватись і
розвиватись і навчатись відійти від
учіння
дати більше простору для гри для вільної
гри для гри яка дає дітям виклик і ми
сьогодні будемо про це говорити тобто
екосистема сьогодні потребує величезної
підтримки і Діти і батьки і вихователі У
нас в Україні багато різних ресурсів є
чудовий ресурс для вихователів норма
про дошкілля де багато різних матеріалів
для батьків
будуть ще більше матеріалів для
вихователів на цій платформі тому що
номо це зовсім нові механізм і зовсім
нові інструменти для того щоб
підтримувати дошкіль я можу говорити
багато Я мабуть зупинюся і буду просто
доповнювати всіх інших наших спікерів
які будуть сьогодні ви
ступати пані Юлія Дуже дякую
Дуже дякую і дуже важливо дуже актуально
такі особливо акцент на вихователі був
зроблений Бо для мене наприклад є два
коли лунає тривога Я молюся двом богам
це боги ППО і Бог готовий виховательки
яка мою дитину несе в укриття тобто
більше для мами сучасної нічого не існує
крім оцієї жінки зазвичай чи жінка яка
дитину несе вокриця і там розлітає і я
завжди Постійно думаю хто допоможе Хто
допомагає цій неймовірній жінці І от в
мене питання до пані Ніна омеляненко бо
ви напевно можете говорити від лиця 5
тисяч і жінок і чоловіків 90% жінок 10
може чоловіків хто сьогодні допомагає
вихователю що вихователь потребує Чи
достатньо уваги вихователю в СССР
екосистемі дошкілля в період війни
Дякую мене чути і що дозволити Я стану
тому що я не бачу очей А мені це дуже
важливо Якщо говорити про нашу асоціацію
підніміть будь ласка руку Хто з вас з
нами
про що це говорить Це говорить про
активну життєву громадську позицію про
що це говорить Ми обіймаємо різні посади
але ми точно знаємо За що ми ми за
якісно дошкільну освіту Ми за
престижність професії вихователя і якщо
не ми то хто запитання
досвід роботи Я дивлюся зараз в очі бачу
пані Марину місто мирноград Донецька
область Я знаю як вони під одним дахом
всі онлайн зібралися як вони збирали
дитячі колектив і батьківську
громадськість як вони допомогли успішно
сортувати школу Я бачу Алла батуринець
Ірпінь для дошкільний заклад щойно
відкрився і в непростих ситуаціях не
простих умовах засновник не розуміє не
хоче йти назустріч але три групи в
закритому закладі працювали я вдячна
Всім при фронтовим областям Запорізька
Дніпропетровська Одеська Миколаївська
Харківське думає що доєднається тому що
в межах нашого проекту 8 тисяч дітей
охоплені дошкільної освіти на базі
будь-яких локацій на базі школи на базі
дошкільного закладу просто було непросто
Чому Тому що це виклик це діалог з
батьками це діалог з Владою я вам дякую
при фронтові області за ваше сміливість
я дякую областям східним я дякую
областям західним і центру за те що ви
також змогли всіх не простих умовах дати
успішний старт кожної дитини виклики
виклики різні такі які були такі
залишаються сьогодні дуже багато
говорили про заробітну плату говорили
про матеріальне забезпечення А ще виклик
який може бути інформаційний
інформацію Треба гарно упакувати гарно
подати і пояснити які сприйняти а потім
гарно використати практично із
результатом А ще я виклик консультати
консультаційний чому я так говорю велика
надія на центри професійного розвитку
працівників Я дуже не хочу щоб вони
повторювали функцію методичних кабінетів
Я дуже хочу щоб вони йшли за вихователем
за педагогам і підтримали те що не за
планом А ти ще треба конкретному
педагогу
виклик організаційний Я за реальну
кадрову організаційну фінансову
самостійність дошкільних закладів у нас
мабуть іще є Треба зробити Да у нас
мабуть є за вказівкою дію Я хочу щоб
реально заклади приймали організаційні
рішення самостійно Я за довіру
між батьками між педагогами і мабуть
досягнення нашої дошкільної освіти
воєнний час це довіра і вміння
домовлятися
От якби не було От мені здається що
батьківська громадськість педагогічна
громадськість дуже згуртувалася тому що
навколо кого навколо дитини якщо
говорили сьогодні про догляд то я
впевнена що саме зараз у нас не догляд у
нас якісні розвивальні простір і якісна
дошкільна освіта і тому з того що я
починала і закінчую Я безмежно Дякую
кожному Я вірю що слово вихователь буде
звучати гордо будь-який момент а війна
нас навчила бути сильнішими мужнішими і
витримати все що нам дає доля заради
кого заради дитини заради взаємодії Я
дуже люблю це слово взаємодія тому що я
в ньому бачу дві великі літери буква д
дитина дошкілля і останнє яка говорить
про те я особистість Я дорослий заради
дитини заради дошкілля
пані Ніна ну після вашої Перемоги можемо
розходитись бо в принципі ви все сказали
плюс аудиторія в нас в основному
асоціація то будь ласка не розходьтеся
але дуже-дуже дякую дуже важливо дуже
проникливо Я завжди коли ви говорите
Плачу і сьогодні Також я думаю що тут не
тільки я
так Ну дійсно дійсно дійсно дійсно все
що ви кажете це правда І дійсно
Наскільки я зрозуміла Хто допомагає до
е-е працівникам дошкілля це працівники
дошкілля і це основна така потужна
рушійна сила але тут вище дуже
сказали багато про батьківську спільноту
що в період війни об'єдналася
батьківство дошкільна навколо дитини і
тут в мене питання вже до
спеціалістки
соціальної поведінкових зміна Анастасії
бо вона в нас знає батьків
дуже-дуже-дуже Розкажіть будь ласка що
сьогодні батьки
думають відчувають і хочуть від дошкілля
є Які садочки закриті як вирішуються
батьками питання дошкільної освіти які
з'явилися альтернативи які альтернативи
потрібні
Дякую Анастасія чутно мене
Дякую дійсно ми видели поведінкових змін
в більшості робимо те що ми робимо
робимо дослідження і досліджуємо ми
батьків завжди ми хочемо чути їх болі
хочемо розуміти їх потреби що
відбувається що ми можемо зробити від
дитячого фонду юнісеф аби покращити їх
життя або зробити
якісним їм життя аби Ну дійсно полегшити
ті болі які в них є і на жаль з ті
Дослідження які ми робили в період з
2022 року на 23-й рік кількість дітей
дошкільного віку які не відвідують
дитячі навчальний заклад вони
збільшуються не на велику кількість але
з
50-8%
Вибачте будь ласка на 62% збільшилася у
23-му році при цьому батьки розглядають
дитячі дошкільний навчальний заклад як
осередок де вони можуть навчатися вони
хочуть віддати дитину для того щоб піти
на роботу для того щоб забезпечувати
свої родини вони бачать садочки як
осередок того де діти спілкуються
соціалізуються де за ними доглядають Це
де вихователі є наставниками тютерами
для них і для них дуже важливо
отримувати якісну дошкільну послугу яку
вони можуть але на жаль Обставини такі
що не всюди можна відкрити садочками всі
це розуміємо різні обставини є
по-різному областям десь не можна через
безпеку десь в більшості не можна діти
не можуть відвідувати тому що немає
місць у цих садочка 40% батьків говорять
про те що вони чекають місце в садочку
більше року що робити діти ростуть кожен
день цей рік вони не можуть втрачати
тому на ці всі виклики ідуть Скажімо так
альтернативні форми дошкільної освіти
створення якісного україномовного
контенту який зараз у ну під час війни
це поштовх до того що різні організації
почали створювати цей контент про почали
думати над альтернативами Я думаю що
багато хто з вас чув про
дитячий садочок онлайн
скажу що ми почали знімати його в
березні минулого року і ми думали тоді
викли лючно про дітей і батьків але
впроваджуючи цей проект Ми зрозуміли що
він використовується і вами і
вихователями тому що в той момент коли
е-е дитячий навчальний заклад переходить
на змішану наприклад форму або онлайн це
полегшення тому що ви можете надіслати
ту чи іншу серію батькам І вони зможуть
долучитися і Ну щоб не втрачати цей
процес щоб не втрачати цей зв'язок з
освітою нам дуже важливо тримати зв'язок
між батьками
дитячим закладом і дітьми тому що
Дослідження які ми ще до ковіду робили
свідчать про те що
лише 17% батьків можуть оцінити як що
таке якісне дошкільна освіта розділилися
от Минулого року дослідження про те що
майже половина на половину батьків
вважають що краще одні вважають що краще
бути з мамою інші вважають що краще
дитині бути вдень з кваліфікованими
співробітниками які з ними слідкують які
допомагають зростати розвиватися тому
тут
ключовий Фактор нашої взаємодії вашої
взаємодії з батьками що довести що перша
освітня ланка дуже важлива підняти її на
інший рівень створювати альтернативні
форми чому кажуть повертаючись до
альтернативних форм
дитячі точки спільно які працюють по цій
по всій Україні вони показали те що є
попит на альтернативні ці послуги
середня статистика показує що дитина яка
знаходиться батьки які приводять дітей у
спільноточки вони в середньому
знаходяться десь півтори-дві години на
на цих точках Тобто ми бачимо попит і
навіть на короткострокові заняття і така
модель показала себе ефективною ми
готові до співпраці з громадами з
департаментами для того щоб пілотувати
різні форми і моделі
дошкільної освіти для того щоб у кінці
кінців полегшувати життя і батькам
покращувати життя дітей і давати
надавати якісну освітню послугу яка може
відгукуватися на гнучкість цього часу і
швидко реагувати дякую
Анастасія Дуже дякую і дуже такі цікаві
цифри я почула які чомусь до цього не
чула що от половину батьків вважають що
краще вдома А половина що краще в
закладі де працюють професіонали хотіли
почути думку аудиторії бо ви спілкуєтесь
з батьками Ви маєте досвід такий з як ми
кажемо з полів я чи змінилася на вашу
думку
ставлення батьків під час війни до
навчального закладу якщо змінилося то як
в яку сторону Що Чим дихають батьки
зараз чому Ну бо я наприклад боюсь свою
дитину вести кожен день але Я веду тому
що я вірю в освітній в освіту і я знаю
що дошкільна освіта дуже важлива Чи це
так само зараз для всіх батьків питання
до аудиторії А ви ценіть ручку або я
просто знаєте як пані Юлію оберу іду іду
іду
Ну я вважаю що всі батьки зараз бояться
того що безпека - це перш за все як ви
кажете Але ж я зі сходу як вже сказала
Ніна Володимирівна і Ми пройшли коли
запропонували проект коли ми
підготувалися спочатку у нас була 10
дітей які батьки яких були не проти
привезти дітей для того щоб дві години
проводити
в садочку але ж на кінець проекту у нас
було 16 батьків вже тобто Всі практично
батьки які були в громаді на той час
дітей старшого дошкільного віку і вони
казали і ще з інших садочків приходили і
казали що вони хочуть того щоб Діти
прийшли Чому Тому що соціалізація у
дітей зараз немає майже тому що це дуже
важлива коли діти і спілкуються і
спочатку дуже важко вихователям знайти
оцю знаєте спільну мову з дітьми які
мало того що психологічну травму мають і
вони вже майже рік були відвикли від
вихователів від того ж спілкуватися але
я все одно за то щоб проводити такі
зустрічі щоб діти все ж таки були поряд
із кваліфікованими вихователями і поряд
зі своїми
дякую
[оплески]
Вітаю всіх Я з Києва з міжнародного
садочку Меридіан що я хочу сказати коли
ми починали працювати в минулому році то
небагато батьків Да прийшли до нас
садочок але з часом Довіра зросла і дуже
багато батьків за цей час прийшли саме і
за довіри що з нами з вихователями з
педагогами дітям спокійніше і надійніше
чим вони наприклад самі вдома або навіть
з батьками у квартирі тому що наприклад
ну такі умови або світловідключали не
було Да навіть дітей нагодувати тому що
електроплити а в садочку завжди є і
гаряча їда і укриття і завжди діти
зайняті завжди діти граються вони
спокійні і За цей час ми дуже вдячні за
цю довіру за те що вони нам найдорожче
да своє і ми намагаємось не підводити їх
за за цю довіру зросла Довіра
збільшилась кількість дітей і ми в цьому
тільки раді дякую
[оплески]
щиро дякую дуже-дуже важливо було почути
і така прозвучала фраза в садочку дітям
спокійніше от вона така дуже важлива що
таке робиться в садочку де знаєте
навколо 36 дітей да одна вихователька в
тому на своїм проблеми але дитині там
спокійніше і в мене питання до пані
Марини як наша екосистема в умовах війни
адаптувалась до дитини до її почуттів як
себе дитина почувається в садочку в
системі в екосистемі дошкільної освіти і
як це екосистема яким чином дитині
допомагає переживати все що відбувається
навколо
Дякую Анастасія а Підкажіть будь ласка
мене чутно
Вітаю Вітаю всіх присутніх Дякую що
знайшли можливість долучитися сьогодні
щиро радію бути присутньою на цій панелі
поруч з такими спікерами це неймовірна
честь Дякую Анастасії запитання Ми
сьогодні на дитину в екосистемі
дошкільної освіти дивимося і на мікро і
на макро і на мезо рівні зачіпали вже і
батьків і вихователів і напевно
я говорячи про садочок і дитину в
садочку ще декілька слів скажу про
безпосередньо саму дошкільну освіту і
трішечки
торкнуся тих процесів які відбуваються
на державному рівні зокрема
розроблення нової візії освіти до 20-30
тому що мені здається що зараз для
дошкілля є таке вікно
можливостей англійської мови Building
Back Back зараз у нас освіта маємо
освіту в умовах кризи і якраз одним з
принципів цієї освіти в умовах кризи і
реагування на ту кризи яку ми
переживаємо є можливість зробити краще
відновити цю освіту краще І
якщо повернутися до дитини безпосередньо
в дитячому садочку ми розуміємо що
дитині спокійніше в дитячому садочку
чому вона знаходиться там в соціумі Вона
знаходиться там з кваліфікованим
дорослим який був підготовлений який
пройшов курси підвищення кваліфікації
який навчився емоційно регулювати дитину
який навчився фасилітувати групову
динаміку який знає як підтримати дитину
коли їй важко а дітям важко тому що вони
в першу не відчувають психологічної
безпеки так наші дітки ми знаємо всі і
ви знаєте краще аніж ми 100%, тому що ви
бачите діток з вихователями щодня що
дітки йдуть в укриття і вони співають
пісню Ми крокуємо викриття але питання
чи це чи та радість на обличчях дітей
коли вони співають цю пісню чи вона
реальна Чи це дітки ховають якісь свої
травматичні переживання стрес і очевидно
що ховають і тут наше завдання як
дорослих підтримати дітей в цей період а
підтримати ми можемо тільки тоді коли ми
самі будемо емоційно стабільними і якщо
запитали чи допомагає
екосистема дошкільної освіти дітям Так
звісно вона допомагає вихователів
навчають ми екіпіровані так як за Ісусом
екіпіровані і ми допомагаємо їм тримати
фронтам та таке освітяни тут екіпіровані
курсами навичками технологіями і так
далі
єдине що у нас в Україні якось не зовсім
прийнято до цих пір
пройти оцей курс прийняття і проживання
емоцій від початку до кінця ми знаємо що
нам потрібно ідентифікувати емоцію
прожити її і підтримати дитину в цьому
процесі але самий Відчуваючи і
переживаючи цю кризу не можемо цього
зробити тому допомагаючи дітям Мені
здається що важливо попіклуватися і про
самих себе подумати про те як ми можемо
підтримати себе для того щоб далі
продовжувати підтримувати своїх діточок
у дитячому садочку звісно будучи
амбасадором дитячої гри я не можу
сказати про те я не можу не згадати про
те що дітям потрібен доступ довільної
гри ми знаємо що це право дитини яке
зафіксовано в Конвенції ООН про права
дитини а знаємо що є стаття яка декларує
право дитини на участь у грі дозвіллі
відпочинку і так далі є Генеральний
коментар №17 який дає нам визначення гри
і говорить що це процес який
відбувається будь-де будь-коли який
ініційований дитиною і який містить три
ключові ознаки це по-перше радість яку
дитина переживає це виклик коли вона
щось долає коли і в цьому процесі
розвивається і це відсутність будь-якого
будь-якої винагороди за цю гру і От коли
я говорила про те що зараз у нас є вікно
можливостей в дошкіллі А ми розробляємо
стратегію Міністерства Міністерства
освіти розробляє стратегію і от
поставити оцей фокус на гру тому що ми
вже у нас державний стандарт який
декларує ігровий підхід як основний
діяльності не підхід якось основний і
вихователі знають що нам потрібно
гратися лишилося зробити останній
невеличкий крок дати вихователю
практичні інструменти як фасилітувати
гру так щоб як організувати в садочку
умови так щоб оці три ключові
характеристики гри радість виклик І
відсутність результату були забезпечені
тому що знову ж таки повертаючись На
жаль до кризи і до війни і до стресу до
травми для дітей гра - це можливість
пережити емоції це можливість їх в
натуральний спосіб
виплюснути наружу показати дорослим про
що вони що вони відчувають і
звільнитися від цієї травми це
натуральний спосіб відновити свою
рельєнтність ну і звісно навчатися тому
така трошки розмита відповідь вийшла і
про
підтримку дитини в дошкільної освіти в
дошкільній освіті і про те що у нас є
можливість Я впевнена що ми цю
можливість використаємо обов'язково з
підтримкою і вихователів і керівників
закладів дошкільної освіти і
громадськими організаціями які зараз
спрямовують увесь фокус на те щоб нова
візія вона все ж таки ставила найкращі
інтереси дитини в центр систем освіти
Дякую Анастасії
Марина Дуже дякую Дуже дякую мені вже
стільки разів сьогодні лунало що
освітяни мають подбати про себе
вихователь має подбати про себе
вихователі дада а потім ідуть додому
роблять домашні справи а вночі вирізають
якихось там метеликів потім на вихідні
фарбують це бомбосховище і малюються
якихось
по кульбабки щоб дітям було краще і
веселіший легше тому я думаю що оця ну
взагалі-то культура вихователя який дбає
про себе в нас ще це моя персональна але
можете зі мною не погодитись але
подбати про себе в нас ще це вихователя
це не сидить от всередині от вихователь
український не знаю коли спинитися
перестати вирізати кульбабки коли треба
просто легкий і дивитись телевізор і в
мене тут питання Я знаю скільки свого
досвіду скільки сучасне вихователь
вкладає в середовище чесно скажу власних
коштів власного часу не оплачуємо щоб
дитині було краще І в мене питання тут
до пані Катерини а як це ну чому
вихователь вважає або вихователька
давайте чесно скажемо вважає таким
важливим це середовищем чому так багато
часу це витрачається І чи це допомагає
яким чином в умовах війни
Доброго дня всім Мені дуже приємно бути
в цій аудиторії і тим більше відповідати
Ну скажімо так на достатньо такий важке
запитання тому що ми настільки звикли до
своїх килимочків за навісочок і картинок
що коли я скажу Давайте ми свій
методичний свербіж трошки призупинимо і
подивимося на середовище з іншого боку
тому що середовище - це не тільки
предметне середовище цей соціальний і
фізичний в тому числі тому мені в дуже
хотілося щоб ми от ма- майже
сьогоднішнього дня або студенти Мої вже
це знають перестанемо використовувати до
середовища слово зона Давайте ми його
залишимо росіянам і Марія Монтессорі
тому що це її
зонування А у нас є красиве слово
українське середовище знаходитеся
всередині
серцевина
вісь осередок
тому говорячи про середовище Я ще раз
нагадаю ви сьогодні чули такий порядок
слів дитина батьки педагоги а в законі
про дошкільну освіту йдеться що
суб'єктами освітнього процесу є в такому
порядку діти педагоги там розкриваються
да І батьки і от якщо ми все ж таки
спокусуємося на ще одному
об'єкту освітнього процесі на батьках
які і є замовниками того чи приведуть
вони дитину чи ні до садочка у нас
багато питань будуть зніматися само
собою щодо середовища чи змінилися воно
звісно змінилося і середовище воно
змінилося в такому плані що ми хочемо і
не хочемо ми розуміємо що дітям у дітей
треба формувати в цьому середовищі
усвідомлений ризик коли я кажу про
усвідомлений ризик Я маю на увазі
набуття дитиною
власного досвіду безпечного перебування
в ризикованій ситуації
ще раз власного досвіду безпечного
перебування
в ризикованій ситуації якщо ми не
повернемося до того що ми маємо навчити
і дитину і себе і батьків
безпечному перебуванню в такій ситуації
ми Ну скажімо Так ми не зможемо
просуватися далі чому Тому що віра в
перемогу Це дуже добре але розуміння
того що це ще не так швидко як нам
хотілося маючи таку сусіда нам треба
навчитися на тренінгах Скажімо так і
себе убезпечувати і убезпечити дітей і
це не онлайн-курси це фізична
фізична Скажімо так ховання підсіл як це
роблять японські діти під час землетрусу
і Скільки і як дитина і чому вона має
бігти в це укриття це треба вводити на
рівні держави і вищих закладів програми
підготовки студентів і в курсі
підвищення кваліфікації не
громадянського
що вже той чоловік який веде цю
громадянську оборону він вже й не
пам'ятає куди там в танк який влізати а
саме так як можна убезпечити дитину
дитина дійсно тільки через власну
діяльність може здобути досвід досвід не
передається він здобувається І цей
досвід тільки через ігрову діяльність і
саме
самостійні вільні самостійні ігри
ініційовані дитиною вони можуть Скажімо
так вправляти дитину в цьому
ризикованому
управляти дитину в ризику У нас є багато
чинників які впливають на те що
ризиковані ігри вони поза межами
дитячого садочка насправді має бути
трошки по-іншому саме ми як педагоги
маємо дітей навчити правильну ризикувати
тому що це еволюційно Незалежно від того
чи будемо ми забороняти дитиною дитині
плигати з цього Скажімо так пеньочка
вона все усе Рівно буде лізти на цей
пеньочок або на паркан і вона залізе на
цей паркан якщо ми не навчимо її
правильно це робити вона полізене дерево
і Чим більше ми будемо дитину у Скажімо
так створювати небезпечні ситуації тим
гірші для дитини і потім гірше для
батьків і нас тому що сьогодні Я
повторюю це фразу кожне вихователь несе
кримінальну відповідальність за безпеку
дитини і за її життя
в журналі дошкільне виховання восьмий
номер є стаття саме присвячена ризику і
ризикованим іграм я не буду повторювати
з місця цієї статті вона така знаєте за
обсягом Скажімо так велика і я
сподіваюся що ті хто працює
безпосередньо методичні служби ви
знайдете можливість познайомити
вихователів саме з цією статтю і чому
Тому що там Дана класифікація
ризикованих ігор пітером греєм Мені дуже
подобається цей на науковець його
дослідження саме з ризикованих ігор для
дітей у нас є багато прикладів що
починаючи від Софії Русової яка написала
статтю про
войовничий дух українських дітей
войовничий дух Тобто це еволюційно
історично і національна наша особливість
і не давати дітям можливість вправлятися
в ризикованих іграх і так званих ігрових
бійках тобто ігри з бійками але це не
поправді але ми все ж таки будемо як
знаєте
тварини намагаються грати так само і
діти намагаються познайомитися один з
одним через гру ми маємо це робити тому
коли ми говоримо про чинники які
впливають і можуть впливати негативно це
передусім об'єктивний чинник - це війна
і всі всі наслідки які є але нема
золотого перетину скільки має це бути
Таких ігор І як це зробити Чому тому що
у нас або скажімо батьки не усвідомлюють
всю небезпеку того що вони Своєю
поведінкою показують що не треба
переживати ми будемо продовжувати сидіти
в кафе і коли йде
повітряна тривога і дитина каже батькові
що татусь повітряна тривога всі викриття
всі викриття Він повторює те що він
розуміє що йому чого його вже навчили в
садочку А батьки продовжують знаходитися
і на закінчення тільки наведу приклад
Уявіть собі Вінниця ранок поїзд
підходить
львів-запоріжжя ротація куплена перонів
військових яких проводжають сім'ї
починаються тривогано яка на на
вокзалі ви знаєте як вона лунає і діти
які знаходяться вони починають кричати
всі в укриття повітря на тривога батьки
не реагують продовжують палити
розмовляють і діти тягнуть дітей тягнуть
Перепрошую батьків в укриття то нам ще
працювати працювати в цьому напрямі щодо
нести до батьків цю небезпеку того їх
поведінки І ще одне це гіпер опікування
навпаки коли дитині взагалі нічого не
Скажімо так не дозволяють і всі проблеми
з брудним одягом там десь кросівки
загубив мішечок це все винні вихователі
да забуваючи про те що дитина для того
щоб вона вижила в цьому Скажімо так ну
такому небезпечному світі Вона має
управлятися саме в цьому і формуванню
усвідомленої ризику На сьогодні - це
одна із таких знаєте потужних проблем
дякую
[оплески]
Дуже дякую пані Катерино як завжди
мінімум 5 революційних думок в одній
розмові навіть не знаю з цього почати за
що схопитись Бо чесно я от Та мама яка
каже дитинстві Ти не переживай то міг ще
нічого не летить ну правда і зараз дуже
соромно стало тому що моя дитина чітко
знаєш треба викриття бігти і я в мене
питання до практики і до всіх тут теж
практики сидять на скільки батьки
готові до того що в садочку будуть
ризиковані ігри а і і і якого рівня
наскільки батьки готові до розмови про
війну і про реальні ризики бо чи всі
батьки готові Що дитині будуть
розказувати чому ми в це укриття біжимо
що якщо ми не побіжимо то ми можемо ну
померти ми ж тому тоді йдемо і це таке
Ну може питання філософське але ви каже
як ви кажете що це
треба вирішити зараз бо він нам на зараз
і в мене питання до аудиторії Як ви зі
збоку там зі своєю практики відчуваєте
наскільки легко з дітьми говорити про
ризики наскільки сформована в батьків
культура вже за два роки і які проблеми
є з цим питанням можна руку підняти і
спікерам і
так чути Добре Доброго дня шановні
колеги я представляю тут Полтавщину
садочок село розсошенці Полтавського
району щербанівської сільської ради Ми
не працювали півтори роки так як
приймали переселенців у себе людей які
вимушені були виїхати і зараз на 1
вересня готуємось на відкриття що я хочу
сказати хвилюється весь мій колектив
хвилюються
люди які навіть ті хто роблять зараз нам
ремонтують все готують всі хвилюється
окрім батьків і знаєте чому я зробила
такі виводи тому що висновки я нещодавно
провела батьківські збори на аудиторію
майже 200 чоловік я взяла цю ношу на
себе не дозволила говорити вихователям
розпочала з того що збудоване укриття
Подивіться екскурсію провели
почала про тривожний рюкзачок що це
повинні батьки наголосила його зібрати
що відповідно відповідальність лежить на
батьках але на нас також ми контролюємо
допомагаємо вам пам'ятки поробили і коли
я почала зачитувати методичні
рекомендації як вести прийом ранковий
коли віддавати І що ми робимо під час
повітряної тривоги перше питання батьків
було А як ви не прийматимете Якщо Ви
зайшли вже в укриття Я біжу на роботу А
як А куди мені дитину я зараз говорю що
перш за все ви наражаєте на небезпеку не
тільки дитину себе і мого вихователя
мого працівника ніхто не буде виходити з
укриття і забирати вашу дитину
Аналогічно Не будем її віддавати батьки
засмутились і так мені говорять А якщо я
не пишу розписку Я їм ще раз показала
методичні рекомендації лист мон все і
говорю я не буду діяти я дію в рамках
законодавства тому що я беру
відповідальність за життя ваших дітей а
якщо вони будуть їсти Ну от кажу ми
йдемо сховище А якщо вони будуть спати я
дивлюсь на цих батьків і я 15 разів я
повторила що шановні те що ваша дитина
не поїсть або не до спить це не страшне
в порівнянні з тим що вона може втратити
життя Ви задумаєтесь хоча б за це і вже
на кінець батьківських зборів коли я 15
разів це проговорила Деякі батьки
погодились і сказали Ну давайте
Давайте я побачила що немає діалогу
говорю Давайте будемо пробувати отут ми
спробуємо хоча б один день а потім
будемо робити висновки і от я такі
висновки зробила на Полтавщині в нас ще
не розуміють що йде війна їм потрібно
всім в садочок навіть тим мамам які
сидять вдома в яких іще по одній дитині
вони просто мені сказали втомились
просто втомились від своїх дітей Можна я
додам ви знаєте Якби я зараз працювала
вихователі Я мабуть зробила так я вклала
б на кроватки ну умовно да всіх батьків
на дитячі кроватки зробила включили
сирену розтягла б їх хоча б там знаєте о
взуття щоб вони взулися схопили
наплічники і погнали через дорогу тому
що в дитячому садочку немає це треба
пробігти дорогу А автомобілі ще їдуть
розумієте а дітей отак роздягаються і
біжать і хай вони добіжать до укриття І
знаєте у вас все буде добре бо на своєму
досвіді вони це будуть розуміти як це
підняти дітей під час сну взути одягнути
і прогнати через дорогу і встигнути
добігти до укриття і все
можна я скажу пару слів чути мене
Ну ми відкрили дошкільний заклад І це
Одеська область місто Южне ми відкрили
всі дошкільні закладу у нас їх там 5 чи
в серпні минулого року і теж казали
колеги Що спочатку батьки боялися в нас
було мала кількість дітей але поступово
У нас тепер повний дитячий садок дітей
Ми працювали працюємо першу половину дня
без денного сну так як в сховищі не було
кількості міст щоб розташувати там дітей
уже після Нового року ми відкрили старші
групи без денного сну замінивши його
поняттям де не відпочинок і сьогодні
наше управління освіти дало нам вказівку
щоб ми з 1 вересня вже відкриваємо всі
групи усіх дошкільних закладах старші і
середні групи відкриваємо на повний день
ви ще не працювали з батьками вас тільки
починаєте ця боротьба щоб не віддавати
дітей під час повітряного тривоги ми це
вже все пройшли і хочу вам сказати що
доходить до того що батьки кажуть нам що
ви вкрали нас дітей ви не віддаєте нам
дітей погрожують нам що зараз викличуть
поліцію Я кажу ми також можемо виконати
поліцію тому що ви зранку нам привели
дітей ви нам довірили тепер це наша зона
відповідальності Ну за цей рік Ми
пройшли багато з ними там різноманітної
роботи і більшість батьків Ну я думаю що
90 десь відсотків батьків уже зрозуміли
що коли звучить сигнал вони іде ведуть
дитину в садок бо просто ворота закриті
Ніхто їх не прийме і А коли діти в садку
і ми в сховищі То тоже більшість уже
реагує спокійно і не йде до нас забирати
дітей але тільки озвучує сигнал біжать
забирати своїх дітей рюкзачки
приготували ми зробили бейджики кожна
дитина підписана тут тобто весь цей шлях
Ми вже пройшли Не бійтеся боїмося але
все робимо
[оплески]
дуже дякую Так пані Ніно вам вам слово
Тиждень тому я була в Новій Петрівці
садок Петрик 220 дітей ходить наживо
62 працівника за 4 хвилини вони в
будь-який момент спускають дітей в
укриття це результат А що йшло до
результату Це ті багато кроків
спілкування з батьками з педагогами
відпрацювання того алгоритм який має
бути ви просто неймовірні
Дуже дякую і дуже колеги дуже приємно
чути постійно постійно лунає і ми
пояснювали батьками після діалогу з
батьками бо все ж таки освітяни і батьки
між в одній команді Да ми ж в одному
трикутнику і це не те що нам дісталося
історично ми з вами не в таких садках
були ми були в садку де відривали
дитину від мами зачиняли перед нею двері
казали ми краще знаємо Тобто ми
навчаємось з не навчаємося самі не маючи
такого досвіду як навчали нас я
дуже-дуже вам дякую за вашу працю Я
дуже-дуже вам дякую за просто Кожен день
героїчно я як мама вам зараз Дякую чесно
не як спеціалістки з дошкільною як мама
дуже-дуже щиро дякую просто земний окрім
тому що я знаю що кожна з вас не за
гроші тут а через покликання і і воно не
оцінимо і батьки це знають як мама каже
ми це знаємо а і хотілося б на
позитивній ноті закінчити тому маленький
Такий сюрприз від зірок
українських які теж знають наскільки
важлива
освітяни наскільки важливі вихователі і
працівники дошкільної освіти тому
попрошу А але може мене не почують
а попрошу відео на наше нам включити на
якому ми завершимо на позитивній ноті
дякую
[музика]
сучасне вихователь на сьогодні для
дитини це справжній друг учитель
наставник і людина до якої дитини біжить
в обійми
сучасне вихователь на сьогодні для
дитини це справжній друг учитель
наставник і людина до якої дитини біжить
в обійми і саме ці люди закладають нашим
дітям впевнений в собі впевненість в
тому що вона може знайти вихід із
будь-яких ситуацій Дорогі наші любі
вихователі першими навчаєте наших дітей
що таке добро що таке зло ви навчаєте їх
дружити бути з собою любити величезну
роботу для того щоб наша нація була не
просто розумна а ще й здорова Саме від
вашого першого доторку залежить те якими
будуть наші дітки дай дитині вчителя із
дитиною виросте хороша людина здатна
творити щось прекрасне Лише зараз ставши
багатодітною мамою і повівши своїх
малюків у дитсадочок я розумію наскільки
це титанічна і важлива справа ми як
батьки трьох дітей про це не уявляємо що
кожного дня переживаєте Ви тому ми
насправді вами захоплюємось
На жаль всі вихователям отримувати
навзаєм таку ж любов яку ви віддаєте
своїм вихованцям бажаю терпіння здоров'я
щоб попри такий важкий складний час ми
все одно мали цю жагу ростити виховувати
найкрутіших українських дітей Дякую вам
дякую що ви є Дякуємо любимо
дякуємо вам
[оплески]
так дорогі колесаночки з ми знімаємо ще
навушники останнє оголошення зараз по
програмі у нас на 16:30